so i was sitting down one time with
stephen
yeah because sammy can't hear okay so so
michael you know who stephen a smith is
sammy you may know who
yeah stephen a smith he's the espn guy
and and and you know one day i'm sitting
down with him in new york and i don't
know if it was connecticut or new york
anyways we're in new york city now
talking to him and i said stephen a a
lot of these guys are your friends like
meaning in the sports world and you come
on and all of a sudden you go after
durant you go after shaq you go after
whoever but these are your buddies these
are your friends
what do you do with that i'll never
forget what he said he says you know you
know what i do it's a great question you
ask
i uh i whisper to them and i said hey
here's what i'm going to say to you
tomorrow i just want you know i have to
do my job and i have to do this
uh you may want to skip tomorrow or you
know communicate with us tomorrow do you
think for for the two of you guys that
are the premier
youtube channels that are creating
content for this world do you think it
may be a good idea for the two of you
guys to communicate if at any time
contents being made that the other
person's name is being mentioned you
think that could solve something like
this moving forward i may be wrong i'm
just asking uh
you know speculating whether that would
help because look we'd like to see you
guys being on better mode than going in
this place we'd rather see you guys
having a better relationship michael
maybe i can start off with you do you
think in the future if you're ever gonna
do an episode if you just say hey sammy
i'm thinking about doing an episode
you're cool with this or you know
something like that or would that not
make a difference
patrick let me end it like this i don't
hear okay i'm upset i don't really turn
out because i will say this regardless
of what he thinks or what he's heard i
did not do that intentionally to betray
him or hurt him or make any innuendo in
any way whatsoever that's the truth i
came out of that sit down and we had
actually liking and respecting sammy and
i happen to really like and love his son
gerard i would never have done this to
betray him or hurt him in any way
never okay and the fact that he did it i
the fact that i did it i apologize it
wasn't meant to be done i'm very upset
that we've had these words because we
shouldn't have had them and you know
what if you would have called me up and
just said you know what what the hell
did you do maybe i wasn't thinking right
we had a kid die in our house you know
it's been a a real
bad thing in our family for the past
couple of weeks but maybe i would have
said you know what sam i know what the
hell i was thinking i'm sorry i
apologized anyway so the bottom line is
i don't know i don't know where his head
is at i'm a christian regardless what he
believes i am upset that i lost it here
a little bit but it's just my frame of
mind right now i apologize to you uh
patrick for you know for getting off a
little bit i normally don't do this you
know that i'm a pretty calm guy
but you know
look
my door is open
my door is open i'm not i'm not trying
to make enemies
whatever sammy wants to do and i mean
that we've said some bad words that
shouldn't have been said just now they
really shouldn't have been but
it is what it is and and i don't know
where we go from here but yeah i'm open
sammy
sammy can you hear me sammy can you hear
me
yes i could hear that okay
uh
i heard him most of it
i think i think what what he's saying is
he's saying that he's open to i know
exactly what he's saying okay
i know exactly what he's saying
and uh i'm not really not a person who
carries grudges
i'm explosive in my personality and
things i do
i'm dedicated to what i do i'm dedicated
to friendship i'm dedicated to things
i've been betrayed a few times in my
life and i don't like it
betrayal just sets me on [ __ ] fire
but he said now
listen i feel the same way when we got
done with
mafia states of america
i actually felt better about him and
knowing him he knows it i spoke to
people
who really don't know him and they would
badmouth him i told him let's just check
them out
leave the guy alone it's
and he knows that all of that stuff
as far as his christianity he could have
it
do whatever he wants with it i know a
lot of people who are
people believing things i believe in god
myself
i believe in religions have different
paths to god you don't have to be a
christian you could be anything an
indian uh uh a jew you could be anything
you want to be to believe in god so i
believe in god as well
but i don't use him up front and i don't
use his name and i don't do all of that
stuff when i get mad or something that
he says about christianity it's like
you're throwing these things in my face
and he apologized for that what he does
right now is is an apology i accept
i apologize things i just said
and i really don't want to hurt him in
any way i don't mean physically i mean
in any of course
there's nothing i want to do to hurt him
there's no reason for that for me
you know and he knows certain things
some of the things you said you know if
he knew that was not me if his wife was
wise enough to know
she's not a good gangster she's not a
street guy
the wife was wasn't up with it was one
day three days whatever this is going to
offend
now if i do videos my son is around my
son he talked good about my son my son
thinks the world
he's not here with me right now because
he had a feeling that this thing would
blow up and he didn't even want to see
it or hear it
because he likes me
so how it's going to go in the future i
really don't know but i'm not mad i
don't have a bet i'm not mad at all in
any way they perform towards them i
don't know about going forward i don't
know if we would do business i have no
idea but you know
i don't really want to hurt them in any
way they perform and and you know sammy
i appreciate you saying that uh uh well
you know having been around you guys for
so many hours and we've spent a lot of
time together both michael and yourself
interviews about conversations i've seen
you upset i've seen you this you know in
different levels
here's a couple of things that's very
random about these the the where you
guys were and where you are today
michael the way i judge is you know his
kids love him they're around him you
know his wife they're together we had
dinner at i don't know where we were at
casa de angelo wherever we were having
dinner or not even cassadine i think it
was shooters when you guys was your
first date 37 years ago i don't know
what uh the time you said to me michael
when you guys had dinner together you
know being married together for three
plus decades there's got to be value
there right and haven't stayed clean for
all these many years there's respect for
that and as sammy for you and i see how
gerard is how your kids are with you
you know there's love there with the
family so there's good things being done
on both sides and both have decided to
move on so if you enjoyed this little
short segment from the podcast that we
did here's another short segment to
watch or if you want to see the entire
podcast click over here take care
everybody bye-bye
[Music]